hi in this video I would teach you how
we could use atom Photoshop to edit
confocal data to process confocal image
confocal images in order to so we have
to open up a Photoshop in our computer
so this is other Photoshop 7 then we
would go to file and then open our
desired image so let's say we open this
particular image and we can check the
image property there is option for image
size you can see here when you click on
image size you say that our image width
is 700 pixels and height is 5 0 4 pixel
now what we can do for our particularly
particularly research experiments we
need to have 1024 1024 pixel image but
this particular image is not 1024 by
1024 so that doesn't matter but for
research publication quality
it requires 1024 1024 however now once
we have this image and we want to create
a new canvas where we would put this
composite image along with its splitted
channels channels in red and channels in
green and for that you can see here in
the right hand side corner the channels
are already splitted concede it in red
Channel now only you can see the green
Channel and you can see the blue channel
and there is nothing in the blue channel
you can see you nones in the green
Channel and their particular protein in
red channel and the whole RGB mode and
now we have to create a new canvas where
we would put all these images then we
have to go to file and new a new option
we have to make a width and height let's
say we make the width and 2 5 0 0 pixels
and this for height will make it 800 and
resolution would be 300
it's research publication quality and
then our color mode would be RGB because
our channel is in RGB actually and
background we want it white and we can
also change the background style and
color so let's hit OK and it would open
a new canvas so after that what we would
do would select our old image and in the
left hand side toolbar there is a
selection option so let's say we don't
want to show our whole image and we want
to show a particular portion of the
image and we want to represent that in
our paper so we have what we have to do
we have to select that portion you can
see I'm selecting this particular
portion and it's now selected then I
would drag and drop into our main canvas
in order to do so you have to click the
drag option the move tool then what we
would do you would move it into our main
canvas you can see it is moved in our
main canvas after that we want to cut
this particular section from all our
channels and without compromising the
size that means our size have to be same
and in order to do so we would go to the
red channel you can see the area of
selection is the same and the size is
not compromised now you would drag and
drop that particular thing and let's
start it with a green channel and we
would drag and drop that same thing so
here is a dragging tool we'll drag that
into our main canvas and we would
arrange it applying some gap and we
would do the same for the red Channel
then we would drag and place it into the
main canvas putting some grab so here in
new canvas you can see all these images
are arranged and now you can crop these
images accordingly you can label these
images and this is how you can
particularly measure a particular
portion of an image and you can make a
panel I hope this video helped you if
you like my video give it a click thumbs
up please subscribe and don't forget to
leave your comments thank you